this is strike action by medical staff
is the right way forward I think in this
instance it is because I think Jeremy
hump has to really be shown that what
he's doing is going to be terribly
dangerous for the health service and
these doctors are striking because they
are altruistic not because they want to
strike I'm it's clear if you talk to any
of them they have a very clear issue and
a real conscience and of course the
health service will be covered by senior
doctors like myself mmm but even so I
mean it must have a knock-on effect even
if it's just through cancelled
operations and things like that
I suppose if it didn't have a knock-on
effect then of course it wouldn't be
effective unfortunately but the trouble
of years that the health service is
struggling like never before
under this government it really is it's
deeply in debt the small amount of money
that George Osborne has just suggested
he puts in will not cover the sort of
debts that trusts have got there is a
massive issue with morale and of course
the health service has always worked
because doctors have been prepared to
work against all the odds to get things
done but I think on this occasion there
are some serious issues which has not
really been fully discussed touch upon
the placements well firstly you know the
reason why the NHS is so excellent why
it's the best NHS why it's the best
health service probably in the world and
certainly there are there are
measurements to suggest that it's
because of the research we do the
clinical research clinical research is
the actual backbone of the NHS and
that's done by junior hospital doctors
who will no longer have time to do that
writing up and one of the issues is that
again and again there is an antithetical
antithetical issue about how doctors
treat research they're not it's not
taken seriously in HS and would this
change in the cotton contract it'll have
serious effect on what they can read
what they can revise what they can
actually do with patients which are not
strictly to do with treatment and of
course how they write their papers and
there are huge numbers of junior doctors
already having difficulty and this is
gonna make it worse but I just I mean
from what I read from mr. hunts
proposals he is talking about space for
quote unquote agreed research well
that's exactly the point and if you read
what Jeremy fara says the head of the
Wellcome Trust
he's clearly unhappy about what so far
has been coming from the Department of
Health and I think you have to accept
that he's not political
he has no ax to grind but he is a very
very famous researcher who runs a very
distinguished funding organization which
funds so much of the work that goes on
in the NHS and he's seriously alarmed by
this quick thought I mean is a low BP
about Jeremy Corbyn I think he's right
in his position on Syria you know it's a
really interesting issue because I think
once I'm absolutely not a core minister
and I think that you know the Labour
Party leadership is in a disarray I have
to say that there's a strong reason why
we probably ought to think very
carefully before going in I think the
risk to innocent civilians is massive
and I don't know you know it's it seems
like history repeating itself without
thinking again what we do after we've
blotted out polarizes I do not believe
that there's any way you can possibly
destroy an entire movement like there I
really think it's going to be impossible
but do you think he's right we know mr
corbyn's views about you know he doesn't
personally want to get involved it's
management of the party he's the leader
now do you think he should not offer MPs
a a free vote a conscience vote or
should he say this is our position it's
my position and you stick with it well I
think it is a conscience vote I think
it's a conscious vote conscience vote
for everybody in Parliament as well I
think it has to be I think you know
going to war is a matter of conscience
and I think party politics sometimes pay
too big a part in the decisions that we
make the idea of the whip deciding what
is in the best interests of something
else seems to me to be that's why the
House of Lords works for example the
House of Lords of course has a whip but
it doesn't take it in the same quarter
way it's it's a suggestion that we might
vote in a particular way but actually
there's no compulsion and there are no
sanctions if you decide to vote against
your whip in the House of Commons of
course the sanctions are very serious
and that's what Corbin is threatening